well here we have hans demon with us and
the commentators want to know what
inspired you to play a4 and what did you
think about his reply a6
well uh
not a lot of tries against berlin so you
have to it's like the one thing you
didn't have any games against so had to
surprise him
well it seems like you got a very
favorable position from the opening when
did you start feeling that you had a big
pull well i always i don't think it i
never
never stopped until in time pressure i
was just the clear breakthrough was very
difficult but it was obvious it was
obvious that i had an advantage the
entire game right uh take us a little
bit through what you consider were the
problematic moments you were trying to
break through throughout most of the
game you got this really nice bind on
yeah yeah so here okay okay of course it
gives plus one and okay this is like low
depth anyways but you can just continue
ricky seven we should be like it's not
on the low depth it's 40. yeah but this
is alicia's engine is a bit uh weird
sometimes but the bishop queen of four
yeah uh i mean well he played
rockefeller okay yeah c3 what did i
remember okay i don't think i made any
mistakes you can continue here i'll tell
you when to stop okay well we can just
go to directly where you want to go
bishop c8 all the way here yeah tick
tick tick yeah king of king f2 uh-huh
quinn did you know g3 yeah i should just
play uh and then he plays king jade i
need to play h4 yeah
well h4 the engines weren't so happy
about the there was this c7 or queen e6
coming to h3 with some so i need to go
knight b6 first and then h4
it wasn't so clear but yes they wanted
to play knight b6 bishop e6 and only now
that the bishop is now that makes a lot
of sense yeah but and then here it
should be
technically lost
wow you would consider it to be that
high of an advantage well 1.3 is usually
should be uh okay it's obviously very
very difficult because
the engine always gives a huge advantage
here and these types of okay like the
pawn structure yes it's obvious what
what is going on but to to find it over
the board is always
it was very difficult absolutely where
did you feel like things went wrong okay
he's like playing so quickly i have no
time and i was just trying to make it to
the time control without um like giving
away my advantage but
at some point um
once i
you know i i just was just making i was
playing without a plan
and lost a bit of control and then i
didn't really have the time to to
to
put significant pressure because i don't
really think it's
i think this is h4 or knight b64 is
the main main try
yeah but after this there's just nothing
yeah especially after queen h4 g5 yeah
just did say that at the end they liked
your position a little bit better
am i supposed to play after 96. okay but
96 king e3 we thought it was very
difficult to find no no of course i saw
it like there's not a question of uh
like okay knight d6 king e3 and out of
five
uh
king d3 no no king uh
no no this is equal king d3 okay ticks
ticks
okay i guess i miscalculated maybe at
this point i was just i'd given up but
uh
no here i would still be able to push
him
a little bit i mean the king on f8 per
house bishop h5 times no but again this
is like so difficult to play with black
because there's always trades and you
you never know if an endgame is just
going to be lost yeah so uh that's true
well it's a good way to start a
tournament you put pressure on the one
around not an easy thing to do he's such
a well-versed berlin player how do you
feel about your starter you seem a
little disappointed
well of course i'm
it's it's not terrible um
the thing is that uh this g3 h4 idea was
so natural to me like the entire game i
just felt like i was completely out
playing him and
there seemed to be a difference in
evaluation of the position and i felt
like
the time management you know could be a
better
h4 chance but even after h4 it's unclear
if i'd be able to win but
i think that
perhaps with a
bit better time management then i would
have
like to play h4 even ip684 is not like
such a difficult thing which is slightly
frustrating but uh
in general i was never in any danger so
at least
it's not that bad
this is your first real incursion into
the elite of chess at the classical time
control how does it feel the preparation
on
the play differently than for example
determining that you played in miami or
other tournaments in which you've played
a rapid time control against this best
of the best players well i enjoy this
much more because i feel like i'm able
to show my best chess here you know
it's very serious preparation and just
the conditions and everything is just so
much better
these rapid events
can be quite dependent on your form and
things can go there's more variance i'd
say in rapid but i'm very happy to be
here of course
to play these players
um you know i expect it maybe to be a
little more intimidated but i feel right
at home here so uh
i'm definitely looking forward to the
rest of the tournament sounds great and
tell us the viewers a little bit about
your adventures because you've been
ping-ponging around the world playing uh
playing chess what happened the last few
weeks
well i was in belgrade and
beginning
to august let's say 13th i
then i was supposed to go play turkish
league and then
champions chester says oh we got an
invitation to miami and i'm like oh
great
so then i fly from belgrade to miami and
then um i'm thinking okay i'm gonna go
to turkish league play five games so i
fly across the world of course
and then once i arrive you know someone
calls me he's like oh you know maybe
you're going to get invited
and then i get uh invited to the
sinkhole cup first it's the wrapping
blitz and then i tried to tell my
turkish like team you know maybe i can
go and uh
let's say that didn't go too well and go
over to them
and turkey is probably not my um
uh where i'm safest uh
and um
so then i was like you know i can't come
so then thankfully they gave me a single
cup invite and then i'm like okay well
i've just played five games in turkey
time
to do my third at cross atlantic trip
all the way back which obviously was
miserable um and uh
but the bright side now is i should be
staying in america for quite a bit and
uh obviously saint louis is much better
than ankara turkey no offense but that
place is absolutely miserable
no offense i'm sure
well thank you for joining us here and
the commentary and good luck in the rest
of your games thank you
indeed good luck uh
you ask a question you get a return very
honest answer there you go and this is